hello my name is gabriel toad i'm the
ceo and founder of canto
biopharmaceuticals
the title of my talk is the following
development of pharmacology for
chaperones targeting the intrinsic
disorder state of towel
or alpha snake land as an
anti-aggregation therapeutic approach
for the treatment of alzheimer's and
parkinson's disease
as an introduction let's look at the
difference between an intrinsic disorder
protein or idp as i would refer to it
in this lecture
and a protein with stable
tertiary structure
[Music]
now idps consist of a dynamic
conformational samples which exchange
between distinct heterogeneous
conformations
i'm illustrating that on the top left
where i'm showing four different
structures of a as a conformations
assemble of an interesting disorder
protein
conversely on the right i'm showing
a protein structure that's folded with
stable tertiary structure
now we estimate that interested disorder
proteins make up approximately 40
percent of the protein coding human
genome
idps are commonly involved in cell
function regulation
and signaling interacting with a wide
range of biomolecules
therefore
idps can become very important
drug targets
however the therapeutic targeting of
idps with small molecules have not been
possible so far
interactions involving idps with other
folded proteins can be highly specific
while b low affinity
idps can be hubs in protein protein
interaction networks interacting with
multiple protein partners for example
one idp can interact with many other
folded proteins
or
many folded proteins interact
with one idp
in the following let's look at the
structural nature of
idp folded protein interactions
the first case
is
referred to as coupled folding to
binding or disorder to order it
transition
a nice example of this is the p53 mdm2
interaction
in this interaction the internal of p53
which is disordered interacts with the
first on 100 amino acids of mdm2 which
is
ordered
the resulting coast
complex consists of
p53
disordered region becoming ordered as
you can see on the right on the figure
in red forming a fairly stable helical
structure
now uh it is likely that the disorders
part of p53 contains what we call a
blocker recognition feature
it's really a
polypeptide segment in the itp that are
that is mostly disordered in the free
state but full during the interaction
with a very specific partner
this this process is very similar
actually to the kind of the induced fit
concept that has been around for a long
time
so molecular recognition features can
mediate binding events in idps
and be related to the disorder to order
transition based recognition
the second case of idp tertiary folded
protein interaction
is when the idp stays disordered
during complex formation
idps can form disorder or so-called
fuzzy complex with order proteins
in which the idp remains the disorders
similarly as it was in the free state
a nice example of a disordered uh
or a fuzzy complex
is the case of the md15 gcn4 interaction
um a simple diagram or a figure of this
is shown on this slide
um in which in gray is gcn4 which is a
stable protein and mdn15 which is a
disorder protein
when they are forming complex
mn15 stays
in a disordered state uh essentially in
a conformational assemble as
as it's shown in this
figure
now this interactions very nicely shows
that
individually weak and low specificity
interactions arising from the essential
disorder nature of
meth15
can combine to produce a biologically
critical function with without requiring
highly ordered structure
let's also look at the timer
thermodynamic basis of idp ordered
protein interactions
disordered binding happens without an
unfavorable entropic cost
which is not the case for disorder to
order transition
in fact during disorder to order binding
of an idp the loss of entropy must be
offset with entopic gains
due to specific molecular interactions
whereas in disorder binding these
molecular interactions can be weaker
idps can misfold and aggregate
causing the onset and progression of
protein misfolding diseases
the aggregation of idps is illustrated
on the slide
the idp's have native conformation
sample
that somehow misfolds
and forms
oligomers and these oligomers end up
transitioning into stable amyloid
fibrils
now we can consider
the oligomers
from a structural point of view as
transient
complexes
in which
the idp is in disorder so it's it's
really
so this is this is basically a disorder
in binding complex
now interestingly this disorder complex
transitions into a stable tertiary
folded
amoled fiber which now we can from a
structural point of view can consider as
a disorder to order transition
aggregation of idps are implicated in
the onset and progression of
neurodegenerative diseases
this table on the slide summarizes the
various idps
implicated
in
different diseases
for example a beta peptide is implicated
in alzheimer's disease
tau in alzheimer's parkinson's and the
number of telepathies alpha synuclein
and parkinson's and the number of
cinuclear and nobody's
tdb43 als ftd
huntington's
huntington and huntington's disease
prion and mad cow disease
most of uh in most of these diseases
these idps
aggregate and end up gaining a toxic
function
and also because of because they lose
their native
structural state
they end up having a loss of native
function
in these diseases idps end up
interacting with their own self to
produce specific solid fibril
pathologies
as aggregation of idps cause
the uncertain
progression of neurodegenerative
diseases
disease modifying therapeutic strategies
has been focusing on stopping
essentially desegregation
now
most efforts have focused on
reducing amyloid fiber formation
um one reason for that was or has been
is because targeting the ml fibrils has
been possible
while for example targeting
polymers which are
trans
transient in nature has been
much more challenging
recently it has become clear that the
most toxic species in this aggregation
process
are dolgamers
therefore
therapeutic strategies are needed that
reduce
both oligomer formation and amyloid
fiber formation
therefore
a therapeutic strategy is needed which
not only reduces amyloid fiber formation
but also reduces oligomer formation
one approach
could be
that we have utilized is to target the
native conformational sample of an idp
with a small molecule
we need to identify small molecules that
bind to the native state of idp
and enhance its essentially native
state and function
and reduce its ability to misfold and
aggregate into oligomers
now the therapeutic strategy to target
the native state of our protein to
reduce its aggregation has been applied
previously successfully
a very nice example of that is
stophamidis
which is a drug a small molecule drug
that has been approved by the fde for
the treatment of transfer tense triatin
amyloidosis
now testosterone is a tetramer even in
its native state and in disease it
misfolds and aggregates
tougher medicine binds as uh
on into the
interface of the tetramer as i am
showing you
on the left
lower corner
and essentially increases the stability
of the tetramer
thereby reducing its the likelihood that
it can essentially dissociate into
monomers and aggregate and form amyloid
fibrils
now a small molecule binding to a
monarch idb could impact its
structural and biological function in in
various ways
we have just spoken about misfolding so
a small molecule binding to ivp could
stabilize
the idp
and thus inhibiting algomar fiber
formation
now small molecule could also influence
its affinity to other interacting
protein partners so it could have an
effect in its signal transduction
function
a small molecule binding to an idp could
affect
the idp's post-translation modular
shampoo and
because it could essentially
reduce
the effect of post-transfer
modifications
and it could possibly even
have an impact on cellular localization
and its actual levels
and turnover
so the question is can a drug-like small
molecule bind to an ibp
specifically with high affinity
let's look at first what we know
we know that order proteins have
well-defined binding sites
in which
a very specific small molecule can bind
the mechanism that has been
described for this binding mechanism is
the key and lock mechanism
now
in the case of interesting disorder
proteins
there isn't one static binding site
uh
however what we know is that there are a
number of very different conformations
uh in the ensemble of an incident and
the structural sample of an
intracellular protein so the question is
how can a small molecule bind to the
sample
with what affinity
with what specificity
and with what mechanism
so in order to understand whether small
molecules can bind to idps our initial
goal was to elucidate whether
binding sites existed in the
conformational assembly of idps
first we wanted to just understand this
from a theoretical point of view
therefore we utilized
confirmation samples of proteins
the
the
search for
hotspots
and then based on the
existence of hotspots we identified
binding sites
we did this using structure-based
modeling techniques
we utilized this strategy first on alpha
synechlin
we used a conformational symbol of alpha
snicklin derived from nmr
measurements
now
the search algorithm that was looking
for hotspots
resulted kind of two extreme results
if he
if he
looked for a binding sex on a compound
confirmation
then we found a number of different
binding sites
uh on the compact confirmation of alpha
synchronous illustrated
and the figure on the left
however when we looked for binding sites
on an extended conformation
we found
almost no binding sites as shown on the
right
this is obviously pretty logical because
in a compact confirmation more binding
sites can assemble than in an extended
confirmation
now let's look at in more detail a very
specific binding site on a confirmation
of alphacyniclin
on the left i'm showing three hotspots
that have been identified by the search
algorithm
these hotspots are
in proximity of each other forming a
good binding site
now this binding site is formed by
uh polyplastic
segments that are essentially
ins in the sequence of offices and again
from each other as shown on on the right
and therefore you can imagine that if
you can bind a small molecule to this
very specific binding site then they act
at the small molecule can act as a
bridge essentially stabilizing this
whole conformation
the second case that we looked at in
more detail was a beta 42 peptide
we generated in this study uh using
microdynamic simulation a confirmation
sample for the aviator 42 peptide
we took the confirmation and sample and
clustered it and found essentially
clusters that have many similar
structures of aviator 42 although they
were generated at different time points
in the microdynamics trajectory
which suggested that cern's
confirmations are first
essentially
transition from one's confirmation to
another but in time
they can transition back to this
original
confirmation
now we took
the these representatives from each
cluster
and
searched for hotspots and binding sites
and found in fact that
different
binding sites existed in these clusters
what's really interesting that uh
certain well-populated clusters had
well-defined
binding sites within them an example of
this is on the top of the right where uh
we show a binding site in the middle of
the structure of uh aviator 42 from
cluster 2.
you could also take these
essentially uh
confirmations and dark
well-known inhibitors of aviator 42 onto
them for example which we did with
curcumin and congo red on the on the
bottom right
this study showed us that
binding sites can exist
a small micro binding sites can exist
for a beta 42 peptide
the third protein system that we looked
into in more detail was how
we used two
nmr derived conformation symbol
of tau
and look for binding sites which we
found
next we compared the propensity of
having a binding site on monorail versus
the propensity of having a binding site
on a folded old ordered protein
as shown in the bottom left
diagram now we found that
the propensities are very similar
interestingly for monomeric tau to have
a binding site versus a folded protein
next we used uh these the binding sites
that we identified on the uh monomeric
uh towel and symbols uh to probe their
metal and blue a tau aggregation
inhibitor could bind
to monomeric tau
now
we found
we found that methylene blue may be
binding very close to cysteine 291 and
cysteine 3 22 and also
essentially
elucidated a binding mode and a complex
structure between methylene blue and
monarch tau
further based on this the
went and tested whether metyline blue
bound to monomeric tau
and found that using
microscope thermophorases that in fact
monomeric a tau bound methylene bro
quite
with high affinity
a full-length human tau bound methylene
blue with a kd of 266 nanomolar and k18
tau bound uh metallian blue with 125
nanomolar
interestingly similar results were
reported by jirong liu's group
who have surveyed a number of
interesting disorder proteins and
reported that uh in fact uh
druggable binding sites make systron
intestinal disorder proteins
moreover they perform local dynamic
simulations similar to to us on aviator
42 and showed that small molecules can
bind to flexible proteins
and um they use the phrase
ligand
clouds around protein clouds as a
mechanism for small molecule protein
binding again resembling the disordered
to disorder
complex formation
that i suggested to happen for
protein protein for idp idp interaction
for example during the aggregation
process forming all the transient
oligomers
we decided to apply our theoretical
findings on targeting the native state
of
idps and small molecules and alzheimer's
and parkinson's disease
now alzheimer's and parkinson's disease
these are chronic degenerative disorders
there is a gradual neural debt as the
disease progresses
which results in loss of memory
cognition motor function
behavior changes and eventually that
an example of how when neurons
degenerate in alzheimer's disease is
shown on on the right
where healthy human brains
essentially essentially
shrinks
and is a tropic degeneration of the
brain
as i highlighted um very specific
proteins aggregate
mostly in alzheimer's of parkinson's
disease in alzheimer's a beta peptide uh
aggregates forms uh plaques
tau protein aggregates performs
neurophobia tangles and alpha cynical
and aggregates into
fibril aggregates and localizing lewy
bodies
the first applied study that i like to
talk
about in more detail is when we targeted
monomeric alpha-synuclein
by small molecules in this study the
identified
binding sites in a confirmation shall
assemble of alpha snicklin
and use these binding sites
as a starting point for high throughput
docking
screen
in which the identified small marker
fragments that bound to these
essentially theoretical binding sites
we ended up testing
over 30 compounds for their ability to
inhibit aggregation and reduce
alpha-syncline
toxicity caused neural debt
and uh one of these compounds uh worked
very efficiently this is called this
compound is shown
on the top right
this component is elan eln482
four eight four two two eight
and and this compound was able to
alleviate a loss of dopaminergic neurons
and narrative retraction in the induced
by
a53 tranning mutant of ulcer fascination
in primary right embryonic midbrain
cultures
essentially uh this is in this
experiment
we overexpressed alpha synuclein a53
via viral vector in red primary neural
mixed cultures and found that the th
plus neural
viability was reduced and when we
pre-treated with eln-484228
you see a significant alleviation of
neural loss
and neurot length
reduction
suggesting that this compound is able to
protect from alpha-syncline toxicity
cause aggregate toxicity
after applying computer-aided drug
discovery methodologies to target
monomeric idps
we decided
to pursue experimental screening
methodologies we identified a very
unique methodology and applied it
on tau
in this uh study
we used high throughput chemical
microarray surface plasma resonance
screen to identify small marker binders
to moderate tau
we did this the following way
which is summarized on the figure on
this
on this slide
we use the chemical microarray their
small molecule are
immobilized on a linker
then if you incubate it and add a tau to
this essentially microarray
and detected
a binding between the monorail tau and
the immobilized small molecule with
surface plasmon resonance
the
the uh partnered with this uh
study uh by graffiti pharmaceuticals uh
now novalex who developed this uh
chemical microarray uh screening
technology
we ended up screening over a hundred
different 100 10 000 small molecules
and
ended up getting moderate
signal-to-noise ratio
with a hit rate of about 0.76 percent
after coming it came from its analysis
of the hits we identified 11 novel
scaffolds and 42 singletons
over about 118 compounds that were
identified to bind to
tau on the basis of this seminary
compounds were selected for synthesis
for heat follow-up
we tested the 70 compounds for the
ability to reduce the aggregation of tau
in vitro
we tested
the compounds on three different
constructs of tau on full length tau on
k-19 and k-18 data 280.
in general we found that the compounds
were able to reduce
uh the aggregation of k10.280
the most
and much less for full length tau
although i have to
highlight that for k19
and for uh
h240 uh for full-length towel we used
heparin to induce the aggregation well
we did not use that for k18 delta 280.
now heparin may be competing for binding
to monorectile with the small molecules
and so it could be impeding
for
their
full ability to reduce
tau aggregation
the diagram
shows
the extent
of the ability of the small molecules to
reduce aggregation
of k18 delta 280 and essentially we can
see that
surprisingly most of the compounds are
able to essentially have an effect in
reducing
tau aggregation
and while they also find a few compounds
that actually ended up increasing the
aggregation capacity of tau
next we tested the compounds for the
ability to reduce tau aggregation in
cells
for this we used the cell model
where we applied n2a cells
induced to overexpress tau
k-18 delta 280.
the detected
aggregate
formation using tylenol fluorine as
fluorescence
in general what we found that most of
the compounds had some impact on
reducing
essentially targeting the cell model and
there were some compounds or a few
compounds that actually reduced
aggregation even
in higher
uh with higher efficacy than we found in
the
in vitro model previously
the public site it hits from the screen
in the peer review journal called
current alzheimer's research
uh a few years ago
and
have in parallel taken forward the most
drug-like compounds and developed them
further
with the aim of developing
drug candidates
as disease modifying
treatments for alzheimer's disease
one of the compounds that we have been
developing at canterbury pharmaceuticals
from this study is cb81
now cb in ed1 inhibits star corrugation
in vitroid in cells
on the left we're showing a
an aggregation assay of tau
vid and without
cbe-81
and
what this illustrates that cb81 is able
to completely inhibit the aggregation of
tau
in vitro
uh on the left we're showing again the
same end to a cell model where
essentially cb 81 is able to
reduce uh the formation of type of has
positive tau aggregates
in a dose-dependent manner
now next we tested
582451 or cb 81 in a drosophila model of
taupati in which the overexpressed human
tau in the modern lands of drosophila
this results in a locomotor impairment
which you can quantify for example by
essentially the climbing speed of
drosophila
drosophila overexpressing
tau
in this motor neurons
causes a reduction in climbing speed as
you can see in this
figure on the bottom
and when we feed
the compound 582451
from essentially day
one to uh
to drosophila
then we are able to alleviate
these
dislocator impairment or essentially the
climbing speed reduction as shown
in this um
in this diagram and this actually um
this this reduction this elevation is is
very very significant
we also apply the same
screening strategy
to identify small marker binders to
monarch office in a clan
in this study um
used monarch alpha cinecline
to screen
using high triple chemical microarray
surface plasma and resident screen
and
essentially identified
also
a plethora of hits
the screen resulted in a hit rate of
0.49 percent
now interestingly
in the alpha cyclin screen we identified
a large number of positively charged
compounds
and probably the reasons for that is is
that the c terminal of synuclein is
negatively charged
conversely in the tau screen we
identified a large number of negatively
charged compounds
and probably the reason for that is
because
tau is overall tau is a positively
charged
protein
this also suggests that
our screened uh screen identified
specific compounds
um uh to uh these the two different uh
interestingly sorted uh proteins
now we took forward also a number of
compounds
uh from the uh from from this
screen
and
tested them in alpha cyclone aggregation
assays
from among the hits that we identified
we published
three compounds that i'll talk about
today
these three compounds ability to
reduce alpha synthetic aggregation is
shown on the slide on the top uh three
diagrams or three distinct compounds for
among them five seven six seven five
five was the most potent or effective
in fact this compound was able to reduce
uh non-seeded fertilization and also
seeded fibrillation of alpha-syncline
and
was able to importantly
reduce
alpha-syncline aggregation in a
dose-dependent
matter
and uh showed near-health maximize
maximal anti-fertilization activity at
substimetric concentration of 25
micromolar in supervision assay when
office nikon was incubated at 75 70
molar
next we tested
the three heat compounds in an alpha
syncline polygonization assay
we used two different types of
organization essay the first one on the
top left
uh is a the diagram shows the results
from a
organization assay in which you use the
split gaussian luciferase
complementation system
uh to detect alpha cynical aggregation
and uh
what we found that five seven six seven
five five was the most potent in an
ic510 micromolar
we also use a fret-based organization
assay shown on the
right
and in this organization assay all three
compounds had an
impact in reducing the algorithmization
of alpha cyclin um and
again five seven six seven five five was
the most potent
next we
used uh and tested
uh seven five seven six seven five five
in an organization assay in cells again
this was a split gaussian blue surface
assay and what we found that
um
because the compound was able to
uh reduce organization uh of alpha
cyniclin now um at the same time five
seven six seven five five did not
significantly change the levels of
office in a claim shown by western blot
next we tested whether 576755
is able to alleviate
the loss of domerting neurons
due to alpha-syncline
over-expression
for this we used a red primary neural
culture mixed culture very
over-expressed
a53
this over expression causes a loss of
th plus neurons as shown on in
the diagram on the right
uh when we pretreat with five seven six
seven five five if we
find
uh and observe that
the alleviate th plus neural loss
suggesting that
uh we are protecting against dopamine or
loss in this
cellular system
let's arrive to the end of my lecture
i'd like to summarize
we find that the native monarch and
sample of idps such as alpha cyclone
tower and a beta contain transient small
molecule binding sites
furthermore we find that diverse novel
drug like small molecules can bind to
the monarch soluble tau and alpha
snicklin
we identified dozens of novel small
molecule binders to monarch town office
neckline your biophysics-based screening
approach
we find that selected novel small
molecules bind to mono for full length
tau or alpha cycline also inhibit
the proteins aggregation in vitro and
cells robustly
selected small molecules that bind to
mario full
were able to rescue tower expression
caused phenotypes and drosophila
moreover selected small molecules that
bite the marks of alpha cynical was able
to alleviate duproject neuronal debt due
to alpha cynical and overexpression
in conclusion
targeting the moderate form of tau and
alpha cynically by small molecules may
be a feasible drug discovery strategy
for the treatment of alzheimer's and
parkinson's disease
thank you for your attention
i'd like to emphasize that this research
was done in partnership with the
following contributors
professor eckhardt akov and ivana
mandakov and colleagues at the
structural biology unit of max bank
institute
professor christopher dobson professor
peter senger hislope professor franklin
alberio
university of cambridge
a number of people from graffiti
pharmaceuticals
including thomas newman
people from the long pharmacy equals
dale schenck
and
especially would like to thank lisa
mcconalog
who is now a professor at ucsf
and colleagues at canterbury
pharmaceuticals